artificial intelligence just
revolutionized science but the key
turning point that i want to talk about
today was actually decades in the making
but before we get into exactly how ai is
changing drug development environmental
simulation and genome sequencing we need
to look at how we got here in 2011 mark
andreessen the creator of the netscape
web browser and a prominent tech
investor wrote a long article in the
wall street journal at the time the
stock market was in turmoil and no one
quite knew what to make of all these new
tech companies that were going public
lots of people were claiming it was a
massive bubble just like the dot-com era
10 years prior but andreessen saw things
differently he argued that software is
eating the world and soon every industry
would be transformed or disrupted by
technology his thesis was strong after
all two decades had passed since the
rise of the modern internet and there
were now over 2 billion people with
broadband access perhaps more
importantly though the cost of starting
a new technology company had fallen by
orders of magnitude a basic internet
application that cost 150 000 per month
to maintain in the year 2000 could now
be deployed to amazon web services for
just fifteen hundred dollars a month
everywhere andreessen looked software
was taking over amazon had
revolutionized book selling netflix had
decimated blockbuster and even disney
had gone through a major technological
revolution through the purchase of pixar
which was at its heart a software
company pioneering advanced computer
graphics andreessen predicted that this
trend would continue and soon even asset
heavy industries like national defense
and energy production would be taking
full advantage of software well it's
been 10 years since andreessen's
prediction and it looks remarkably
accurate in hindsight nearly every new
high-growth company is somehow tied to
software innovation even though software
has been a powerful force for
revolutionizing old industries many
scientific fields were left largely
untouched that is until recently two
major developments in computing are
working together to unlock incredible
possibilities in science first raw
computing power has increased so much
that previously intractable problems can
now be solved using algorithms and
second new deep learning neural networks
are uniquely powerful in scientific
domains taken together we finally have
the ability to build artificial
intelligence systems capable of having
an impact on science so where are we
seeing the most progress we can answer
that question by going back to the 1950s
and looking at the early work of
biologists in 1953 watson and crick
published a paper describing the dna
double helix that twists to form the
latter-like structure we think of today
as soon as we could visualize dna we
wanted to understand it at a deeper
level the goal was always to figure out
the linkage between particular snippets
of genetic code and the cellular parts
and processes that result from that code
while there's been incredible progress
in both sequencing dna and understanding
the genome over the past 70 years we've
always fallen just short of
comprehending the complete picture using
just the dna or rna source code
biologists wanted to be able to
accurately and efficiently predict the
three-dimensional shape of an unknown
protein this is because we know that
structure and function are directly
related in biology the shape of a
protein drives what role it will play
inside of a cell for example membrane
receptors are often cylindrical with
hollow middles so they can connect
properly makes sense but even though all
dna is made up of just four simple bases
human dna can code for upwards of 20 000
different proteins if scientists could
unlock the ability to predict protein
structure from dna sequences it would
allow them to better understand human
disease and even potentially design
custom proteins to fight a wide range of
illnesses the last 70 years have only
yielded small gains in this area though
and scientists had to rely on slow
computational methods and occasionally
even raw intuition in order to decipher
protein structures this was particularly
frustrating because scientists had
already solved the translation between
dna sequences and the amino acids that
formed the building blocks of proteins
the problem was actually folding these
amino acids up into their final
structures which would reveal their true
function and so the protein folding
problem was born and it confounded
biologists for decades that was until a
team of artificial intelligence
researchers came along and changed
everything deep mind was founded in
september of 2010 only a few months
before marc andreessen would post his
now famous software as eating the world
article in the wall street journal while
everyone else in tech was focused on
just building products that they could
put immediately in consumers hands and
start generating profits the deepmind
team was much more methodical they
focused on quietly developing
cutting-edge ai for years before they
were acquired by google in 2014. even
after the google buyout it was unclear
if deepmind was going to release a
commercial product any time soon they
seemed more focused on making headlines
by mastering a wide variety of games
first they beat the world champion go
player lease it all and then a few years
later they reached grand master level in
starcraft 2 but the learnings from these
games would wind up translating
remarkably well to other domains and the
protein folding problem was an obvious
target for deepmind's technology so in
2020 the team announced that their
algorithm called alpha fold had solved
the protein folding problem once and for
all the news was met with a mix of
excitement and skepticism at first if
alpha fold worked well it could
definitely save scientists a lot of time
and money in the lab but it seemed odd
that a company focused on playing video
games could have real impact in the
biology community fortunately there was
already a gold standard competition in
place for assessing various protein
folding approaches and if alpha fold
could win the competition the case would
be closed and the skeptics would have to
give them the credit they'd earned by
the time the competition rolled around
alpha fold was unstoppable the deepmind
team crushed the competition and wound
up posting scores that predicted the
final shape of proteins within the width
of a single atom but academic
competitions can still have limited real
world use sometimes so deepmind needed
to put alphafold to the test in the wild
they found the perfect opportunity while
researching the novel coronavirus using
alpha fold the team was able to
correctly predict the exact shape of the
sars-ko cov2 spike protein which
ultimately went on to be targeted by
vaccines it was an incredible milestone
in the application of artificial
intelligence and biology and it made it
clear that software was starting to eat
the scientific world as well the
accolades began rolling in an open
source version of alpha fold was named
method of the year by science magazine
and the editor-in-chief said the
breakthrough in protein folding is one
of the greatest ever in terms of both
the scientific achievement and the
enabling of future research deepmind had
won the game and solved the protein
folding problem it was a massive
achievement and it validated decades of
hard work in artificial intelligence
research but at the same time protein
folding was just one small piece of the
puzzle when it came to scientific
research
so it was time for the ai community to
expand their ambitions we're now at a
major turning point for applied
artificial intelligence the technology
is finally in a mature state and
enterprising teams of programmers and
scientists are starting to tackle some
of the hardest problems in the world
with extremely promising results
recently an article in an artificial
intelligence magazine called the
gradient outlined four key areas in
which artificial intelligence is having
a profound impact on science so let's go
through them one at a time as we've seen
over the past few years artificial
intelligence thrives on massive data
sets projects like openai's gpt-3 use
huge troves of text data to answer
questions translate text and even write
computer code we're very fortunate that
ai is at its best in precisely the
arenas where humans struggle the most
it's impossible for any single human to
read through every scientific journal
that gets published but that's a perfect
problem for applied ai as an example
let's look again at covid19 research
throughout the pandemic nearly 200 000
articles were published in scientific
journals relating to the virus reading
through all of these papers to try and
glean insights would be impossible for
anyone let alone a busy researcher who's
actively contributing to the fight but
ai can quickly read through all of the
available scientific literature and
create an underlying model for the
fundamental rules data and principles
that together build up a body of
knowledge around a particular area of
science and this doesn't need to be
restricted to any particular area there
are millions of valuable scientific
papers out there with hidden insights
that would be useful if they could just
be surfaced at the right moment in time
while it's pretty obvious to imagine a
medical database that could deliver
better results than google or webmd the
real applications here will likely be
far more technical for example there's a
company called insilico that used ai to
design a new drug to fight a disease
called idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis or
ipf what's interesting about insilico's
approach here is that not only did they
use an algorithm to design the drug
itself they also used an algorithm to
pick the disease that they wanted to
cure the insilico team turned their ai
loose on reams of medical literature
which allowed them to find potential
proteins cells and pathogens that they
wanted to work on there are still
skeptics that believe this approach
won't work and to be fair insilico's
drug is still only in phase one clinical
trials and has a ways to go before
making an impact but if the approach
works it could speed up the drug
development process significantly the
benefits of ai are rarely restricted to
fully replacing a human-operated process
though often ai just helps humans make
better decisions faster and that's where
area number two comes in over the past
few decades scientific instruments have
become vastly more precise once again
scientists are saddled with the burden
of too much data to process and that's
where ai proves extremely helpful more
than 100 years ago all the way back in
1916 albert einstein theorized that
gravitational waves could be a natural
outcome of his general theory of
relativity these ripples in the
space-time continuum were purely
theoretical at least until a group of
scientists at the argonne national
laboratory developed an algorithm that
could process a month's worth of data in
just seven minutes the craziest part of
all of this was that instead of highly
specialized equipment these algorithms
could run on standard gpus this is a
great demonstration of how ai methods
are becoming easier to integrate into
the natural workflow of scientists which
speeds up research significantly but
even specialized scientific equipment is
now benefiting from ai upgrades and this
is our third key area of impact electron
microscopes allow scientists to
investigate the natural world at a much
smaller scale instead of relying on
visible light passing through lenses
like a normal microscope electron
microscopes use electrons to generate
images at higher resolution with more
detail the problem is that data
generated by these electron microscopes
can be noisy and hard to interpret and
that's where ai comes in by recording
additional data about a sample's
physical and chemical properties and
then passing that data to an ai system
researchers have been able to increase
the power and accuracy of their
instruments these basic scientific tools
are critical to efficient research
efforts and it's not just electron
microscopes that are getting an
ai-powered upgrade dna sequencers which
are critical to nearly all biological
research in the genomic era have also
been improved with ai recently a team of
scientists used ai to cut the time it
takes to sequence dna in half and
they're aiming to cut it in half again
soon any time it takes less time or
money to try something you're going to
see more innovation and that's exciting
those small scale improvements are
important but ai is also unlocking new
capabilities on the opposite end of the
spectrum the fourth key area is broadly
called complex simulation and it's
quickly becoming a standard tool in
basic science research as we've seen
time and time again deep neural networks
are capable of solving a remarkably
broad set of problems gpt3 can answer
questions write code and do translation
all at the same time deepmind's gatto
can do everything from playing atari
games to stacking blocks with a real
robot arm all from the same neural
network and now this versatility is
being applied to scientific modeling the
network is called dense and it was
designed by research to build
simulations in 10 different scientific
fields from physics and astronomy to
geology and climate science one single
deep neural network was able to build 10
separate emulators and maintain accuracy
while performing calculations up to a
billion times faster the really key
breakthrough here though is that these
models are particularly good at solving
inverse problems where a researcher
wants to figure out what variables might
lead to a given output instead of
randomly tweaking parameters in a
massive model ai can easily solve for
the set of answers the researcher is
looking for these ai driven simulations
are already having an impact in the real
world and again we need to look at the
covid pandemic to see how in the summer
of 2020 a group of japanese scientists
started building a deep neural network
to model the spread of the virus
throughout the world they wound up
training this network on the world's
most powerful supercomputer and the
results were striking the data they
generated provided critical evidence
that the virus was in fact airborne and
this wound up directly informing public
policy researchers are continuing to
find new applications for ai in the
sciences every day but it's still early
if you want to hear more about the
history of deep mind just watch this
video next thanks a lot